çok
ama çok önemli
hem kendi bölgenin yokluğu olduğu için
bugün de ona eğitim olan insanların
gençlerin yok yer alması bu olması ile
ilgili bunu tekrar tazelenen
söylemiştim niye çok hızlı güzelce
anlattı diye bizim şu an en büyük
sorunudur hemen böyle
9910 yıllarında Aslında ülke
doğum markalarının olması ve
çalışmaları başlamıştır Cumhuriyetin
ilanından sonra
2934 yıllarda güzel
işaret ettiği içinde yer aldığı olmak
üzere birçok
çalışmaya başlamıştır bize nacizane
2010 yıllarda tekrar geçişlerin nereye
gidecek nerede demiş insanlarla ilk
olacaksın gerçekleştirdik
birkaç ilave
buluş
safhasında ve daha sonra yaptığı
faaliyetler yürüten
İşte biz 2005 yılında
[Müzik]
Çalışmalara başladı resmi olarak
yani
tamam bizim aslında En başında verdiniz
bir domateslerin
[Müzik]
artık topraklarımızın tekrar nasıl mıydı
var ama sevgi ezdiğimiz yapmaya
başladınız beş yılda meselenin bu kadar
tabii ağaçları magazin değil onun
için elinden çok hızlı yok olduğuna dair
verilen Aslında
mesela Biraz daha
değil neredeyse
birer tarafından çalışmazsa kaybolmayı
aşamasına geldiğini
ye-2010 yılında hem genel sorunlarla
ilgili hem de altı yılında çıkartılan ya
olan yasaklandığı
bir şeyi
Ne diyeyim asla bir kanunun iptali
değildi
doğum takas yaparken niyetiniz şeydi
yani bu bölgede de ve diğer bölgelerde
kendini yerel doğum
halletmeye çalışalım mı
mı başka bölgelerde hala eşleme Bu resim
konuşma Sağol açıksın var olduğu ile
ilgili nasıl bir buluşma
noktası ve buluşma konusu oluşturma 2010
yılında ilk yazılı
olduğu
bölgede yapılmaya
devam etti bizim
Aydın büyük şeyde yaptığımız
[Müzik]
açtığımızda mı zty sağlık ilave ederek
olma hissi biz burada bu ilişki kurmakta
hiç zorlanmadan çok gayri ihtiyari
hareketle şöyle diyor yerel çeşitler
ve
sağlıklı gıda ile ilgili bir şey
yapacaksın hala bir şey diyeceğim
Başka
bir tarafı
çok uzun
bulunduğu bölgeye adam
[Müzik]
insanların bedensel ruhsal
vücudumuza ne yapacağız
onlarla beslenmeye başladığımız 110 Yıl
320 yılın şöyle bir kaba taslakta
fotoğrafını gözünüzün önüne
getirdiğimizde zaten durumun hangi
noktadan noktaya geldiğinde belki daha
ne kadar
yere gideceğiz nerede görebiliriz O
yüzden araba doğum Derneği
gezerek üretici kadınların ellerinde
bulunduğu yer bularak tekrardan
çoğaltmak
oldu ve hala devam ediyor Bu
bizim biraz kafalarımız ispat olarak o
zaman tabi yaşlı biraz daha küçük bizde
inatçı daha fazla durumda olduğumuzu
Neyse gözden kaçırmışız ama böyle
Bulanıklı aşmış
ve o dönemden ve bu dönemi hangi aynı
çalışmalarını geldiğimizde birazcık
takımdan ilgili Pazartesi sekiz yıl önce
geldi yaptığı çalışmada hala söylendi
yeme içme alışkanlıklarına bağlı veya
hücre bağlı olarak yetişkin hala hayatta
olduğunu Hatta belli çeşitlerinin
ticaretin yapıldığı için de vazgeçilmez
olduğunu tespit ettikten sonra
çalışmalarını
hem başını hız var o yüzden 8 yıllarda
birçok farklı bölgede kahve olduğum
Derneği adıyla olmadı daha iyi farklı
işimden farklı içten altında gel soğuk
çalışmaların Hem aktif olarak
destekleyip hem alabilir bizzat destek
vermesi yine pazardaki en son aşamada
geldiğimiz Nokta Yer onların
ve yönetsel tarımın bize uygula da devam
edecek gerçekçi bir hale modeli
gibi
oldu falan gibi değil gerçek zaman devam
edelim Bakalım
hedefindeyiz bunda ne oldu Cevap
istiyoruz ki bir kamusal alan
kendini ve dünyada aynı birçok buldum
zamanın neler oldu
istiyoruz ki öncelikle üretim alanında
olan yani aşağıda olup metinler kopmuş
birinci derecedir çocuklarının gelip
Anne babalarından bir dönem öğrenmiş
veya anne-babaların Biz çok çiçek miyim
diyerek çocuklara öğretme diye
geleneksel tarım modelleri hayvancılık
modelleri
içinden tutunda şey oldu sarmaya kadar
devam edecek bizi al faaliyetin O
uygulanabileceği bir Alanya bu alan aynı
zamanda bir dakika sonra kötü oldu
hayatımda hayatını kazandı eylemi O bir
süre ya eğitimi
alanlar olan insanların bir araya
gelerek birbirlerine ki bilgiyi hiçbir
şekilde bir mi istiyorsun da kabul
etmeyen ekonomik taşlı olmayan bir
biçimde birbirlerine
düşündüğümüz bir alan çalışmaları devam
ediyor
doğum Derneği'nin genel
çalışmaları en başında başlar
bulunması
dağıtılması kısmını sahip olmayan
köylere ilçelere beldelere
devam ediyor
Biz bunun yerel tohumların başarısı
olması gerektiği iddiası İsrail
işlemlerine annemizin Avrupa Birliği
fonları
çok uzak kalması ve kendi o
O yüzden faydalanması ilgili sahip devam
ediyoruz yaklaşık 17 Hala da
beni kendi üretim özneler ile kendi
üretim
çalışmaları bir şekilde devam ediyor bu
Emsal bir
küçük ama etkili bir model var hala bir
yerlere not
durumda şimdi sağlıklı gıdanın yerel
normal varmış ve bir şimdi olduğumuz ne
kadar takip nedir arkadaş zaten çok diye
bir desekte
artık şehirde uzun zamandır
uzun zamandır topraktan kopmuş olan
şehirde
Ondan bir haber ama zaman zaman böyle
dediğimiz gibi Çok uzun zamandır mi
11de konuşlandığı için kendini
koruyabilen Her şey hastalık zararlılar
ucuzluk odası bu olaylar
Meryem tahmin edilemeyen bu haberleri
karşısında kendini muhafaza edilen
boyayabilen devam edelim olduğu için
yani insan ile bir diş müdahaleye
ihtiyaç duymadığı için her zaman insana
en yağış en yağışlı bizim haline enişte
yine hali Olabilir halde idi özellikle
İkinci Dünya Savaşı'ndan sonra da bir
çok öğrenci diyor Ben bu konuda
iki dünya savaşı yerel tohumların
bilinçli olarak
zamanı et
bu topraklar değilseniz bırakmayın
insangücü ortadan kalkmış falan insan
nüfus ama yine de biz diyor ne yapılacak
ya soğuk olmazsa gelişmiş sonra
geliştirilmiş işte onlar olmazsa
insanlara çıkalım sentezi güzeli olmazsa
olmaz Bir bitmezler olmazsa yetmez o
kadar ve yani
dönemde hem de duygusal psikolojik ve
bizim hayatımıza bir bomba yeşil Devrim
adı altında dünya şöyle
yasasına
piyasa
bizim
üstümüzde gidiyor yani şey diyoruz biz
köyde kendine hala satıldı Olmuş
satılabilen Bizim hiç 14 bin yıllık
boğaz olur da bu toprakların
olmayan bir şey olmasın
bu
pakete forması ticarete konu edilmesi
bizim için yaşamadım şeyde Merkezi Dünya
Savaşı sıralarında alayım ve
bu açlık korkusu
yüksek beğenilen yüksek çağır virüsüdür
düğün değil mi tohumların etkili menzili
muayenenin çok hızlı
ve bizim bu aslında Görece avantajlı
dövme çok fazla ayarlama gösterdiğimiz
bu dönemde
Belki bugün içinden olabilirim ediyoruz
şimdi dinozor çıkabilir
[Müzik]
temizlenmesi ve geri dönüşüyor oldukça
uzun ve ve alacak Bu duruyor yani Artık
neredeyse Ege'de Kuzey gider veya Güney
Akdeniz de ya ticarette olan yerlerdeki
İblis olmayan kullanımını özelliği
395 diğer domates Patlıcan gibi ticarete
konu olan ve iyiye gider
kibritoğlu mı pakette uygulanıyor satın
tohumu kullanımı 195 bu İç Anadolu'da ve
Karadeniz'in kuzeyinde veya doğanın
ortasında ve
haliyle Bugün artık ya olmazsa aldı
mıdır
zaman kayboldu
geldiğimiz durumda dünyanın
standart hastalıklar veya standart
Bugünlerde en Yaşıyoruz
olağandışı bir şey varsa fazla acaba şey
demek istemiyorum
onu da
iş bu hale geldiyse bu Eğer onlardan
kaynak
sağlıktan uzaklaştığımız yer soğumadan
kaynaklı az su ya da diğer olmadan
kaynaklı az yağ kullandığımız bir dönem
gerçekleştirdik diyerek Biz kendimizi
konumlandığı kendimizi burada durmaya ve
buradan
fazlasıyla çok daha aksini iddia etmiyor
edilen
Bundan on yıl önce ya
o da o kadar su istemez Aslında yokmuş
gibi
doğal gibi ismi
ile ilgili şiir
bu ne alemde durdun mu yeniyim burada
sana gelmek üzere Evet o zaman birkaç
cümleli
yerelde onlarla ilgili artık bizim Sen
yaptığımız işte uzun zamandır
kaldığımızda mıdır
bilinmez
onlarla sağlıklı daha çok büyük toplu
bir
Peki insan değil sağlık daha ulaşması
iyi ne yapması gerektiği gibi
gelmez biz
[Müzik]
bu dünyada yaşayan insanlar nasılsın
İbrahim ulaşmalıyız saldırıda nereden
değil
üreticisine tekrar geri dönüyoruz üretim
alanlarını okumamış hala köylerinin la
la la söylenebilen kendi kötü olmasa da
aynı sanki insanları bir araya gelerek
kedicik oluşmasından geçiyor Yani bazen
de çok zor geliyor sağ ol
sağ ol be nerede olur
köyden ama onlar da yiyor
köylünün
hayatını sürdürmektedir ben şimdi ama
inanın bizim birilerini zehirlemek
yerleri öldürür
kimyasal gübrelerin diğer girdi
Ne bizim
[Müzik]
bizim bir tane aklımızda Biz yemeği
içmeyi üretmeyi hayvansal üretimi iyi
bilen bu
insanlar ve bölgelere sahip İnsanız biz
şu an için hala vermekteyiz getirirken
yöneticinin bir araya gelip bizimle
acilen yıllar geçmiş lazım yapabiliriz
bir üretmeye biliriz
devam edebiliriz Bu bilgiye sahip bu
bağıl iyice olmaması zayıflaması için
önce karşılıklı un
artık
üretiminde
ciddi bir işaret ettiğini Unutma bu da
[Müzik]